support booth University in the
production of more videos by visiting
the link in the description below where
you'll find more details thank you and
enjoy okay so in this video we're going
to talk about the discovery of the
electron by JJ Thompson in 1897 via the
cathode ray tube experiment I guess the
first question we should ask ourselves
is what is a cathode ray tube it's
really just a sealed off container of
glass with no air inside of the tube and
shaped kind of like this if you turn
your head to the left it kind of looks
like a flask of some sort anyway at the
at the left end here we've got two
little pieces of metal and each of these
pieces of metal is connected to a power
source so when power is applied what
happens is a beam shoots off from this
first piece of metal all the way through
to the end of the tube and it causes a
little glow at this end of the tube
because of the special coating on the
inside of the tube it's a phosphor
coating so it lights up okay so Thompson
sees this and he thinks okay what is
this - or where's this tubes ray where's
this ray made up of where's this beam
made up of anything sand wonders okay
does this thing have a charge of some
sort electrical charge so what he does
pretty genius
he grabs a magnet and he holds it kind
of around the tube okay and he tries to
see what what's going on with though
with the Ray this affects it and so what
he notices is that the beam bends the
Ray bends in this magnetic field that's
the observation that he makes the Ray
bent in a magnetic field so his
conclusion was that if that because this
Ray bent in this magnetic field that
this Ray must contain charged particles
right because something that's charged
will will Bend in the magnetic field
okay so then he wonders okay what charge
is this okay so then what he does is he
takes two plates two metal plates one of
them being positively charged and one of
them being
we charged and he wants to see what
which direction the beam will Bend in so
he checks it out and he sees if the Ray
bends towards the positive plate the Ray
bent towards the positive plate so what
was the conclusion there well if
something if this beam is attracted to
this positive plate then it must contain
a negative charge right because opposite
charges attract so his conclusion was
that the Ray must consist of negatively
charged particles okay so then what so
there were a few different observations
that he made three different conclusions
that he drew from them so we already
said that he the Ray bent in the
magnetic field so that led him to
conclude that the Ray must contain
charged particles right so there was
something charged in the beam and then
you noticed that the Ray bent towards
the positive plate which meant that it
must have negatively charged four
particles
specifically right and then what he did
was he switched out the metals that he
had in the cathode ray tubes we did it
for a bunch of different metals and what
he found was that the Ray was identical
for all different medical metal cathodes
that he used so his conclusion there was
that the negatively charged particles
are in all matter okay so we have these
negatively charged particles and these
negatively charged particles exist
regardless the beat the beam being is
assuming the Ray is identical for all
these different metal cathodes what that
means that these negatively charged
particles exist in all matter so he come
he combined that that uh that this these
different pieces of knowledge as well as
the fact that these negatively charged
particles which he called electrons by
the way he called them electrons he
combined that with knowledge of these
electrons
we're about 1,000 times smaller than the
smallest atom that was known right
smaller than the than a hydrogen atom
right which is a smallest atom which
meant that there is something smaller
than an atom thus disproving Dalton's
model right of the billiard ball model
because if he says is it as one of his
postulates that atoms are tiny
indivisible particles right yeah well if
there's something these electrons namely
and there are thousand times smaller
than the smallest atom then there must
be something that means atoms are
divisible into sub atomic particles
right so these observation these
observations led to it was called the
plum pudding model and we'll talk about
the details of that in actually the next
video okay so that'll be in the next
video we'll see what that looks like
Thompson also did well what he also did
was he calculated the electrons charge
to mass ratio okay so this little II
with a superscript that's a that's a
minus sign that is represents the
electron because electron of course
starts with letter E and the minus sign
indicates a negative charge so he
calculated the Matt the charge to mass
ratio which is e over m okay and where
eise pacifically is the magnitude of the
electrons charge because the actual
charge of an electron would be negative
e because neck electrons are negatively
charged so and then of course M is the
mass so the ratio between the two he
found to be one point seven five eight
eight to one times 10 to the 8th c / g c
stands for coulombs so it's coulombs per
gram and coulombs are basically the SI
unit for charge okay so now what was
interesting is that he couldn't actually
the charge itself or the mask itself
right you couldn't charge you couldn't
calculate either one so we calculated
the ratio okay so the question is what
about the charge and/or the masks
themselves right
well Robert Milliken's oil-drop
experiment kind of reveals the secrets
of that question okay so we'll see that
in a future video as well hope that
video was helpful and kind of
understanding the cathode ray tube
experiment definitely be sure to watch
the plum pudding model video to make
sure that you understand what's going on
as far as the the development from from
Dalton's model to this new model thank
you for watching if you found that video
helpful be sure to LIKE and subscribe
for more content also follow move
University on the different social media
links in the description below thank you
and happy studying